Bah alors, qu’est-ce que tu fais tout seul à l’écart ? Vous n’êtes pas tous en train de vous tomber dans les bras ?
Tu as des problèmes de sociabilisation ?
Mais non, tu étais tout seul, je me suis dit je vais venir te voir, c’est sympa quoi.
Ah !
Alors, la relève, ça va ?
Qui c’est qui avait ma chambre ?
C'était laquelle ?
Bah, celle avec la poutre.
Elles n’avaient pas toutes des poutres ?
Si si, y a des poutres partout.
Pour l’équilibre de la maison, c’est normal.
Y en a une où il y avait vraiment une grosse poutre, en doré.
Du coup, elle est là ?
Oui t’inquiète.
J’ai mes chances cette fois, tu crois ?
Ah non, lui, il a une guitare.
Ne me dites pas que vous allez faire un feu et nous jouer du Saez
ou mettre des sarouels ou je sais pas quoi là ?
À coup sûr. 4 heures de route avec lui, je peux te dire, il lâche pas sa guitare le mec.
Jamais.
Il ne conduit pas du coup.
La musique, comme pratiquement toutes les formes d’art, est une discipline passionnante
parce que l’on peut théoriser des dizaines de concepts
pour en expliquer les mécaniques et les composantes,
et pourtant il y aura toujours une dimension inexplicable, presque magique qui fera dans notre cas qu’un morceau sonne bien ou…
moins bien.
Et aujourd’hui ce que l’on va faire c’est justement essayer de comprendre une de ces dimensions inexplicables qu’on appelle le groove.
Alors pour ne pas griller les étapes, on va revenir rapidement sur ce qui compose la musique.
En résumant nous allons avoir deux dimensions.
L’aspect harmonique, donc là on va mettre tous les principes de solfège qui font généralement très peur aux gens,
comme les gammes, les accords, les tonalités,
en gros tout ce qui va définir les notes que l’on va jouer, ou ne pas jouer.
Et ensuite on a l’aspect rythmique, comment on va placer ces notes dans le temps.
Et c’est ça qui va nous intéresser aujourd’hui,
étant donné que l’idée de groove est bien sûr étroitement liée au rythme et au tempo,
c'est-à-dire à la vitesse d'un morceau.
Déjà du point de vue étymologique nous n’avons pas en français de mot pour traduire la notion de groove,
qui en anglais est un mot qui désigne à la base un sillon ou une rainure,
ce qui sert d’image à un placement rythmique que l’on suppose exceptionnel vu qu’on a quand même pris la peine de créer un mot rien que pour ça.
Et si la notion de groove n’existe pas en français c’est aussi parce que c’est une notion qui n’est apparue que très récemment dans l’histoire de la musique.
En effet, au XVIIIe siècle personne ne se penchait à l’oreille de son voisin pendant une représentation
de la symphonie n°38 de Mozart pour souffler un discret :
« Wouhaou, comme ça groove sévère ce truc ! »
Non, c’est un concept qui n’est apparu que bien plus tard, dans le courant du XXe siècle,
avec la démocratisation du jazz, et des styles de musique joués par les populations afro-américaines au début du siècle,
en gros les styles que l’on ne considérait pas à l’époque comme de la musique savante.
En effet on remarque que très souvent les musiciens que l’on appellera ici “classiques”,
comme par exemple les membres d’un orchestre philharmonique,
ont une conceptualisation du rythme très différente
d’un musicien de jazz, ou d’un musicien de rock
par exemple.
D’ailleurs petite anecdote sympa,
au départ on utilisait beaucoup plus le terme “swinger” que “groover”,
et ça parce qu’à l’époque le style le plus répandu c’était le jazz, et le jazz ternaire plus précisément.
Quand une musique est ternaire, donc quand on peut diviser le temps en trois, on utilise le terme swing,
et quand une musique est binaire, quand on peut diviser le temps en 2, on utilise le terme groove.
C’est exactement la même idée, elle est juste appliquée à deux contextes différents.
Et pour en revenir à notre idée de conceptualisation du rythme, là où dans le classique la notion de tempo est un concept presque liquide,
il peut varier en fonction de l’interprétation d’un musicien pour des pièces jouées en solo,
ou alors l’inertie d’un orchestre fera que lorsque le chef d’orchestre bat la mesure,
généralement les musiciens jouent avec un certains décalage par rapport à ce tempo ;
des genres de musique plus contemporains ne peuvent pas se permettre d’avoir un tempo aussi variable,
et tous les musiciens se doivent d’être synchronisés sur cette même vitesse qui conduira le morceau.
D’ailleurs on peut voir ici que la notion de groove et de placement rythmique n’a très souvent de sens que dans un contexte qui réunit
plusieurs instruments ou plusieurs parties rythmiques.
Le groove va presque toujours naître de l’interaction de plusieurs instruments entre eux.
Du coup ce que je vous propose c’est qu’avant d’aller plus loin
on fasse ensemble un petit cours de rythme histoire que l’on soit tous sur la même longueur d’onde.
Je vais essayer de vous enseigner les bases rythmiques nécessaires à quiconque veut faire de la musique
pour vous permettre de vous mettre dans l’état d’esprit
du musicien qui veut réussir à groover.
Pour mieux rentrer dans le rôle du professeur de musique, je vais avoir besoin d’élèves dissipés et réfractaires,
et j’ai déjà ma petite idée d’où les trouver.
Alors, ce serait super important pour moi si on pouvait ramener tout le monde pour qu’on puisse s’amuser de manière ludique.
- Bah oui on va faire...
- Valentine, je sais que tout le monde t’écoute, que tu es un peu la leadeuse du groupe,
si tu pouvais t’en charger, ce serait vraiment super.
Il doit y avoir une erreur.
Te dévalorise pas, je sais que tu y arriveras, et que ça va être vraiment magnifique.
Alors l’outil indispensable au travail du rythme ça va être évidemment un métronome,
ou un “click” comme on dit dans le milieu,
ce click ce qu’il va faire c’est qu’il va émettre à intervalles réguliers un son sec,
et le B A-Ba du musicien ça va déjà être de réussir à suivre ce métronome,
par exemple en tapant des mains de manière régulière en même temps que lui.
Le premier exemple, ça va être de taper...
Bon jusque là rien de bien compliqué, mais pas d’inquiétude, on va passer aux choses sérieuses.
Maintenant que l’on a pu voir que notre cerveau pouvait assez facilement se synchroniser sur un rythme régulier
déjà existant on va s'entraîner à faire une chose que les musiciens font en permanence sans même y penser,
c’est subdiviser ces même temps en des cellules rythmiques plus petites,
mais toujours régulières, qui nous permettront ensuite d’avoir plus de liberté rythmique.
On commence avec la croche, il faut réussir à faire entrer deux coups par temps, donc on  va taper sur le temps et sur ce qu’on appelle les “et” entre les temps.
Ça va faire “1 et 2 et 3 etc.”
*Clap ! Clap ! Clap ! Clap ! Clap !*
On voit que c’est plus compliqué, mais on y arrive toujours à peu près,
maintenant on va faire la même chose en faisant rentrer 3 coups par temps, c’est ce qu’on appelle des triolets.
1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, 1, 2
*Clap ! Clap ! Clap ! Clap ! Clap !*
(La PLS est présente)
Là on commence à perdre des gens.
Et pour nous achever on va diviser un temps en 4 subdivisions bien égales,
c’est ce qu’on appelle les doubles croches.
Du coup là où pour les croches on utilisait la technique du 1 ET 2 ET
pour se repérer plus facilement,
pour les doubles croches on utilise très souvent la technique américaine du “1 EE AND UH”.
Mentalement ça va nous permettre de plus facilement diviser un temps en quatre,
et en sachant toujours sur quelle subdivision on va se trouver.
*Clap ! Clap ! Clap ! Clap !*
Certains sont au bout de leur vie.
Ça fait mal au bras.
Nan mais ça c'est vraiment !
Voilà on va s’arrêter là, je suis sadique mais il y a des limites tout.
Du coup, vous avez entendu parler de la rumeur ?
La rumeur ?
Le Florent là, il vient de débarquer avec une guitare, ce soir c’est barbeuc,
il veut serrer quelqu’un, c’est évident. La question, c’est qui ?
- Wow, comment tu parles ?
- Et puis pourquoi ça t'intéresse ?
- Je sais pas, comme ça.
- Bon, c'est pas nous en tout cas.
- Ce serait bizarre.
- Bizarre pourquoi ?
- Parce qu'on est casées.
- Ça, ça ne veut rien dire.
On est casées ensemble. C’est ça qu’elle veut dire Monté.
C’est la magie de la saison 2 du Vortex.
Tu vois, Monté, le Vortex c’est beaucoup d’amour.
Donc, ce n’est pas parce que tu arrives avec une guitare ou avec des menottes dans ton pyjama dino que tu penses forcément à serrer quelqu’un.
- Et tu peux te servir de ton petit doigt.
- Ah oui.
Du coup, je me suis demandé si les animaux pouvaient aussi danser en rythme.
Parce qu’on connaît les célèbres parades nuptiales des oiseaux et même de certains espèces d’araignées qui
font des espèces de danse, même s’il n’y a pas de musique.
Et y a des chercheurs qui ont étudié ça.
Ils ne se sont pas demandé précisément si les animaux pouvaient groover, mais s’ils pouvaient danser en rythme.
Parce qu’à part les humains, la majorité des animaux ne répondent pas à la musique.
Ils ne dansent pas pour le plaisir, sauf peut-être chez les perroquets.
Et du coup, il y a un chercheur du nom de Patel qui a étudié un perroquet qui lui s’appelle Snowball,
qui arrive à danser plus ou moins en rythme.
Et en plus de ça, Snowball est incroyable,
il a carrément créé 14 pas de danse différents,
il était dans cette période là dans une phase d’exploration de ces mouvements,
une phase de créativité,
donc le chercheur a étudié les mouvements de Snowball.
Il a regardé s’il dansait vraiment en rythme ou si c’était du pif.
Donc ils ont mis ses chansons préférées. Parce qu’il a des musiques préférées.
Et ils ont changé les tempos, en l’accélérant ou en le ralentissant.
Et Snowball arrive à être synchro et à s’adapter selon les tempos
même s’il est synchro que 20% du temps.
Donc, il arrive à percevoir un rythme régulier d’un signal complexe.
Il arrive à être flexible selon les tempos.
Et en plus de ça, il a un comportement régulier sans lien avec la production musicale.
Et ça, selon le chercheur, ce serait les trois critères
qui permettraient d’indiquer si un individu est capable de percevoir un battement extérieur
et désynchronisé son corps.
Donc, de danser en rythme.
Sachant que Snowball ne fait pas ça pour la nourriture. Il n’y a pas de système de récompense.
Et ce n’est pas non plus une parade nuptiale, il n’a pas envie de pécho son humain.
Du coup, ce serait une espèce de comportement social pour interagir avec les humains.
Sachant qu’il danse plus longtemps quand les humains dansent avec lui.
Il y a aussi une autre étude qui a été faite sur une lionne de mer du nom de Ronan,
qui elle a été dressée pour danser en rythme, à faire des battements de tête selon le tempo.
Et autant sur la précision que sur la durée, elle fait mieux que Snowball.
Sachant que l’hypothèse de base était que seule les espèces avec des capacités d’imitation vocale pouvaient danser en rythme.
Hors, contrairement au perroquet, ce n’est pas le cas chez les lions de mer.
Et du coup, il n’y a pas que les humains qui arrivent à danser en rythme, il y a aussi d’autres animaux.
Et t'as rien écouté.
♫ Wonderwall d'Oasis par Valentine ♫
Parfait.
On peut voir que chez des non musiciens, le fait de synchroniser son rythme interne sur un tempo régulier,
ou de rajouter des subdivisions à ce tempo, c’est pas si facile que ça.
C’est d’ailleurs pour ça que la régularité est une des caractéristiques les plus essentielles du batteur,
qui va remplacer dans le contexte d’un groupe,
le métronome dont nous nous sommes servis pour nos petits exercices.
Si le tempo n’est pas régulier et ne fait que ralentir, accélérer, ralentir et ainsi de suite
ça va être très compliqué pour les auditeurs de synchroniser leur rythme interne à ce tempo fluctuant,
et ça va rendre l’écoute fatigante et désagréable.
C’est un peu comme être en voiture avec un mauvais conducteur qui ne ferait que donner de grands coups d'accélérateur avant de freiner brutalement
au lieu d’avoir la vitesse la plus fluide possible.
Du coup, est-ce que jouer de manière régulière est ce qu’on appelle le groove ?
Pour répondre à ça, le meilleur moyen c’est d’utiliser une boite à rythme.
Je viens de programmer un pattern extrêmement simple qu’on retrouve dans beaucoup de genres
et aussi dans beaucoup de morceaux différents,
on va avoir la grosse caisse sur les 1er et 3ème temps,
la caisse claire sur les 2ème et 4ème temps,
et notre charley va jouer sur absolument toutes les croches.
Forcément comme c’est une machine, tous les coups vont être placés à leur position théorique la plus parfaite, et on va voir si ça groove.
♪ Battement régulier ♪
Évidemment ça groove pas,
on a un ressenti très rigide, très artificiel, qui est donc à l’opposé du feeling que l’on veut avoir quand on groove.
Donc ca serait beaucoup trop facile de se dire que pour groover il suffit de savoir respecter un tempo.
On va avoir deux principaux outils pour nous permettre justement de donner un peu de vie à tout ça.
La première chose que l’on va pouvoir rajouter, ce sont les nuances.
Grossièrement c’est l’idée d’ajouter des variations de volume à ce qu'on joue,
cette idée là en musique on lui donne le nom de dynamique.
Le fait d’ajouter ces variations de volume ça va non seulement venir apporter plus de variations à notre pattern,
mais ça va aussi apporter des variations au niveau des textures sonores.
Peu importe l’instrument que l’on pratique, que ce soit une batterie, une guitare, un piano ou que sais-je,
si l’on joue avec différentes nuances, on va aussi jouer sur les différents timbres de l’instrument.
Par exemple sur une guitare si l’on joue une corde très doucement on va avoir un son chaud,
peu riche en fréquences aiguës
alors que si l’on joue très fort on va ajouter beaucoup de claquant à la corde,
on va gagner énormément en aigües, et ça va venir modifier non seulement le volume,
mais aussi les caractéristiques sonores de ce que l’on entend.
♪Bruit de corde♪
Donc si je reprends mon groove de tout à l’heure, mais que je commence à ajouter des nuances,
et ce que l’on va appeler des ghost notes, donc des petits coups joués très doucement placés à droite à gauche
pour ajouter du relief,
on va obtenir ça.
♪Exemple avec la boite à rythme♪
On voit que ça commence à être un peu plus sympa, ça pourrait presque donner envie de danser un peu !
Mais ça ne groove pas encore.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il manque encore un élément essentiel : l'imperfection.
Ou même pire : l’imperfection parfaite.
Alors qu’est ce que je peux bien vouloir dire quand je parle d’imperfection parfaite.
Derrière ce concept déjà il y a l'acceptation du fait
qu’un humain ne pourra jamais jouer de manière aussi précise qu’une machine,
mais quand un musicien joue il va se trouver maître de cette imprécision rythmique,
et on va pouvoir observer trois familles de placement rythmiques.
Déjà le fait de jouer le plus précisément possible, c’est ce qu’on entend
par “être en place” en jargon de musicien.
C’est un placement qui va transmettre un sentiment de puissance, de force indéboulonnable,
et on va retrouver ça souvent chez des groupes de rock comme AC/DC par exemple.
♫
Ensuite on peut aussi jouer très légèrement en avance du temps.
Là si c’est bien fait ça va communiquer un sentiment très dansant,
et si c’est mal fait ça peut être carrément désagréable,
comme si on nous poussait un peu aux fesses pour terminer le morceau plus rapidement.
C’est un placement que l’on retrouve parfois dans le funk à des tempos élevés,
on a certains morceaux de James Brown par exemple, qui ont besoin de cette sensation qui pousse un peu pour fonctionner.
Où alors ça peut être un ressenti que l’on retrouve chez certains solistes ou chanteurs, comme par exemple Charles Aznavour
qui, quand il reprend des standards de jazz, va avoir l'habitude de se placer très en amont rythmiquement.
♫
Et enfin le troisième placement possible va bien entendu être derrière le temps, très légèrement en retard.
C’est souvent ce placement là que l’on va interpréter comme du groove,
et c’est très à la mode depuis quelques années surtout dans des styles comme la neosoul ou le hiphop un peu retro que l’on appelle Boom Bap,
sachant que les deux artistes ayant popularisé ce genre de feeling sont D’angelo, et le producteur de hip hop J Dilla.
On va retrouver l’un des meilleurs exemples de ce groove dans les batucadas brésiliennes.
Très généralement un instrument qu’on appelle le chocalho va jouer des doubles croches d’une manière très particulière,
au lieu de jouer quatre coups parfaitement espacés par temps comme on a essayé de faire tout à l’heure.
chaque coup va devenir de plus en plus court, comme si la fin du temps avait une gravité plus importantes.
♫
C’est important de préciser que ces différents placements rythmiques sont des armes dangereuses
et nécessitent une grande conscience musicale pour être utilisés à bon escient.
En effet la différence entre jouer devant le temps et juste avoir tendance à accélérer est très fine,
tout comme jouer au fond du temps peut vite se transformer en ralentir et tirer tout le monde en arrière.
En effet ce n’est pas parce qu’un musicien joue derrière le temps qu’il va modifier le tempo.
C’est ici qu’on récupère notre idée d’imperfection parfaite,
le secret du groove ça va non seulement être d’avoir une maîtrise totale du tempo et de sa régularité,
mais aussi de savoir comment se placer par rapport à ce tempo pour transmettre une émotion particulière.
Comme on vient de le voir, chaque style de musique a ses codes rythmique, et la maîtrise de ces codes nécessite en plus de pouvoir rejouer ces placements à première vue “imparfaits” en boucle,
et toujours de la même manière.
En musique il y a un concept qui est très amusant et très vrai à la fois c’est qu’une erreur jouée une fois, c’est une erreur.
En revanche la même erreur jouée plusieurs fois d'affilée de la même manière, c’est un choix artistique.
Sur ce sujet, on peut citer le bassiste et compositeur Michael League qui pose un constat super intéressant,
c’est que plus on répète et on entend un groove, plus il devient intéressant, contrairement à une phrase très technique
qui elle va avoir tendance à très rapidement nous gonfler.
Le groove a ce pouvoir hypnotique de rendre la répétition passionnante.
Il y a des artistes qui ont bâti leur identité musicale entièrement autour de cette idée.
Je vous défie de relever le nombre de breaks que les batteurs de James Brown font en moyenne sur ses morceaux.
Un break, en gros, c’est une phrase rythmique qui vient briser le pattern répétitif d’un batteur
pour annoncer des changements de parties dans un morceau par exemple.
Et chez James Brown il n’y a quasiment aucun break,
simplement parce que le point le plus important du morceau, ce sur quoi il repose, c’est le groove,
et pas la démonstration technique ou la surenchère d’arrangements.
Pour illustrer ça nous allons reprendre notre séquenceur, mais au lieu de confier la partie rythmique à la machine en programmant un pattern,
je me suis enregistré en train de le jouer,
en essayant d’appliquer les éléments que l’on vient de voir,
et au passage j’ai pris des sons de batterie un peu plus réalistes,
pour ajouter un côté plus texturé et palpable à ce qu'on va entendre.
Le premier élément que nous allons jouer c’est le charleston et nous allons rajouter une légère syncopation
sur les croches de manière à ce que notre coup ne tombe pas exactement au milieu du temps.
♪Exemple♪
Après ça, j'ai ajouté la grosse caisse, le kick.
De la même manière, j’ai distordu en quelque sorte le tempo de manière à avoir des doubles croches
qui sont beaucoup proches les unes des autres que de “vraies” doubles croches.
♪Exemple avec kick♪
Et enfin la touche finale de mon beat
ça a été de jouer les caisses claires très légèrement en avance
par rapport au charley.
Comme ça, j'ai pu créer un jeu rythmique avec, à la fois le charley qui traîne, et la casse claire qui avance.
♪Exemple avec snare♪
Comme on peut le voir c’est non seulement le fait de jouer sur ces placements en léger décalage par rapport aux temps qui créer tout l'intérêt de ce genre de groove,
mais aussi leur répétition qui permet de les légitimer,
et qui permet aussi à notre cerveau de trouver une logique dans ce qui peut ressembler au premier abord à des imprécisions.
Ce qu’il est très intéressant de constater aussi c’est que très souvent les logiciels d’enregistrement
ont une fonction qui s’appelle “humaniser”
que l’on peut appliquer sur n'importe quel séquenceur de batteries,
et ce que cette fonction fait c’est qu’elle va très légèrement décaler tous les coups et aussi modifier aléatoirement
la vélocité des coups pour rajouter de l’imprévisible,
et par conséquent donner un rendu viscéral qui sera beaucoup plus naturel à l’oreille.
Donc, là jusqu’à maintenant on s’est principalement intéressés à la manière dont une partie de batterie peut groover,
mais il faut savoir que ce soin du placement rythmique est applicable, et appliqué,
à absolument tous les instruments impliqués d’un morceau.
Et comme nous l’avons vu juste avant, il n’y pas un groove universel,
certes nous avons pu voir que le groove reposait en grande partie sur une réappropriation du placement rythmique
par rapport à un tempo fixe,
mais cette réappropriation va varier en fonction du style de musique, et de l’instrument joué.
En effet une partie de batterie laid back, donc placer légèrement en retard rythmiquement
ne ne peut exister que si un autre instrument joue en place pour nous servir de référence.
Par exemple dans la neo soul il est très commun que le duo batterie et basse joue légèrement en retard
tandis que les autres instruments comme le piano ou la guitare jouent parfaitement en rythme.
Et c’est ça qui est génial avec cette notion de groove,
c’est que c’est à la fois très “analysable” comme on l’a fait tout au long de cette vidéo
et pourtant extrêmement difficile à cerner et à appliquer.
En effet, si la notion de groove en arrière peut être comprise par presque tous les musiciens ayant un minimum de bases techniques,
il n’y en a pas tant que ça qui pourront je jouer.
C’est aussi pour ça qu’on utilise autant l’anglicisme feeling,
et le mot “âme” quand on cherche à décrire la qualité d'interprétation d’un artiste,
tout simplement parce qu’il reste toujours une dimension inquantifiable et propre à tous les individus
qui fait que jusqu’à maintenant, la musique reste quelque chose de profondément humain.
Toujours est-il que même si les machines essaient de simuler l’imprévisibilité du jeu humain,
et arrivent parfois à s’en rapprocher très légèrement,
le groove est et restera quelque chose de profondément vivant.
Peu importe l’instrument pratiqué le groove ce n’est pas quelque chose que l’on joue mais quelque chose que l’on ressent,
et c’est ça qui est beau.
J’espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu et que la notion de groove est maintenant un petit peu plus claire pour vous.
N’hésitez pas à vous abonner, à liker, à partager, vous connaissez tout ça.
Si vous voulez qu’on en discute, on a aussi un Discord que vous pouvez rejoindre.
Et pour ceux qui voient cette vidéo à sa sortie, je vous rappelle que je suis en direct sur Twitch pour discuter de tout ça.
… parce que si tu veux, dans une société d’abondance, tu n’as plus de rareté,
tu ne devrais plus avoir besoin d’argent.
Non mais tu vois, si on y réfléchit en fait,
Un Créatif là, la saison d’avant,
c’est lui d’où venait tous les problèmes en fait.
Tu vois là on est en vacances, on est bien, il est pas là,
comme par hasard.
Est-ce que tu sais ce que c’est le fruit le plus végétarien ?
C’est la pastèque.
Parce que pas steak.
C’est quoi ta chanson préférée ?
C’est Jolie Poupée de Bernard Menez.
Tu sais, la version plateau chez Michel Drucker.
Ouais, alors, je la connais pas,
mais si tu veux, je peux faire Wonderworld.
Ok.
Là vous voyez, on vient d’atteindre un tournant dans la soirée.
C'est-à-dire ?
C’est à dire qu’il fait froid, qu’il commence à faire nuit bien noir,
donc on ne va pas y couper.
On va se taper du “Jeune et con” de Saez ou du “machin le vent” de Louise Attack.
Je crois qu’il a prévu “Redemption Song” de Bob Marley.
Et voilà, qu’est-ce que je disais.
♪Knockin' on Heaven's Door par Valentine♪